But you got to do that.
Whenever I hear people talk too much about politics,
even myself included my own words,
I'm like,
you're talking about like a rigged game.
It's like you're,
it's like you're talking about pro wrestling.
It's like you're talking about something that's you pretending that it's real,
but you know what you know,
you know,
of course the government is corrupt as fuck,
but when you're talking about stuff like that,
like it are,
the election's rigged.
Our,
um,
do our votes count.
The one thing that I learned from this,
this,
these midterms is that if your vote didn't count and it was an and a,
it's all decided like pro wrestling,
then there wouldn't be all this voter fraud and all these,
uh,
computers that can not,
you know what I'm talking about?
I'm not sure.
I'm gonna have to get a,
I'm talking about the way,
once you're in office,
the way things get,
nothing,
they're not decisions since now I get it.
But when I'm saying this from,
from,
uh,
the elections,
you see that your vote's do matter.
There's a lot of corruption and fraud going on.
But if it was all rigged,
like WWE,
they wouldn't need to do all that.
They were like,
no,
it's still,
it's still the real system because a lot of people think it's not a real system.
Like it doesn't matter.
They already decided and they're just going to put them in.
No.
The way they,
they actually decide is,
is they decide who they're going to rig the machines full.
Yes.
But the vote's still count.
You just got to make sure that there's no,
uh,
you know,
shenanigans going on.
I certainly do count,
but what would,
where it gets really squirrely,
and this is where politics get goofy,
is in,
why do politicians do what they do?
Do they do what they do to support the people or do they do what they do because
special interest groups of infant,
not only that,
here's what's really,
wow.
So,
so Capitol Hill,
when you're in Congress,
they call that the farm team.
Because in Capitol Hill you spent six years,
seven years,
let's just say,
or a senator.
Now when you're a senator for,
I dunno,
10 years,
when you're on capital hill for as a congressman,
first six for 10 years,
you develop real connections and relationships with government officials who
make decisions.
You also understand how government works.
You understand who's actually influencing who.
So now what do you do?
So let's say you lose an election or let's say you decide,
I bet I made my hundred and 60 grand a year,
can't really live on that money.
You go to k street,
you join a lobbying firm and,
and because you've been there for six or nine or 10 years,
you know a lot of people and that lobbying farm goes,
hey,
we'll pay $1 million now.
And all you gotta do is drive to Capitol Hill every day.
Get in there and influence,
use your connections so that we,
we can get what we want from government.
So corporations hiring,
lobbying firms to lobby for their bottom line.
So now you're working to influence government.
And the problem is when you were in Congress,
you know that,
you know,
you have a job waiting.
If you can make great connections.
And now Washington becomes an economy of influence.
That's the game,
right?
Yes.
I'm fucking,
you gotta have a Lawrence Lessig on your God damn podcast.
He can explain it.
He's a Harvard professor and that Motherfucker,
you tell me about the podcast you did with him.
He'll break it down.
I did.
Yeah.
Listen to that.
I'll say I sent it to you.
I think it's Lawrence Lessig.
He's,
he's,
he breaks it down.
He wrote a book called Republic lost and he's got a couple of Ted talks.
But that dude,
yes.
And basically he said,
your government doesn't represent you and here's why.
Here's how it works.
When he breaks it down and you go,
it's simple the way he breaks it down,
cause he's a constitutional scholar out of Harvard when you were like,
fuck it.
And what he said was fascinating.
He said,
Washington's a place where even if you're a good person,
you must behave in a corrupt manner if you want to survive.
And that's when you have problems when good people have to behave correctly.
Yeah.
The bright side,
the bright side of all that is,
uh,
the fact that there is like people getting suicided and bribery going on,
that that means that there's hope,
that there's good people inside the government that you got to watch,
you gotta Watch your ass or you know,
we're going to have,
we got to hire someone because we don't want to go to jail.
So the fact that all that's done,
I'm gonna kill you.
They can just get you out.
Or,
you know what I'm saying is the fact that there is all that bribery and
suiciding,
that means that there's good people in there that are,
are going after,
uh,
the bad people.
But to me,
I look at the bright side as I used to think,
there was no hope.
I used to think fuck it.
Like when,
when the bushes were an office,
Clinton,
Obama,
I was like,
I didn't pay attention to shit.
I just said they're all corrupt.
It's all rigged and it's all,
you know,
there's nothing you could do about it.
But,
um,
you know,
over the last couple of years,
since Trump got into office now I'm like paying attention.
There are some good people trying to do some good shit.
Like Trey Gowdy.
Listen to that motherfucker.
Trey Gowdy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
What are you talking about?
Gates?
No politician with these people.
The congressmen.
Oh Man,
there are great people going after the bad people.
That's why there needs to be bribes and suiciding and blackmail.
The reason there's black males,
because there's good people in there.
If everybody was bad,
they would.
Why would you blackmail anybody?
The problem is it's really subtle the way they can get you out though.
Because when your donors are telling you which way to vote,
you're,
you as a politician go in there with all your ideas and you can't vote your
conscience.
There's,
you got to put a lot of bad shit.
You got for show the money.
You're preaching to the choir over here.
I'm not going to defend.
So you fix that.
So,
so Lawrence Lessig has,
one of the ideas he talks about is anonymous donations.
So,
so watch your a politician,
right?
I'm a corporation.
I give your a or an eye through a super PAC or whatever it might be.
I give your campaign a lot of money.
Now you're a regular dude.
You're not corrupt.
But human beings,
when somebody gives them a real hand when they needed it,
you can't help but to feel a little indebted.
Of course.
What if all,
what if there are two ideas?
What if you had a voucher system with all of us were given a certain amount of
money every election cycle and we were allowed anonymously to give that money to
whoever we thought was a viable candidate.
It be anonymous or what if all donations were anonymous?
What if you didn't,
if you couldn't say who it was from,
but if you know you got a lot of stuff from GE or you know you've got a lot of
stuff from Lockheed and there's a bill that comes up for Saudi Arabia to buy a
bunch of tanks or whatever,
or weaponry,
it's going to be very hard for you to vote against that.
And if you do,
those people that got you in power last time aren't going to get you empowered
them basically figured out a way to make bribing legal.
This is just to give you stuff the way it works,
Bro.
Take care of you and you add money to your campaign,
but then don't exactly tell you what to do,
right?
But you know what the fuck.